[Music]
you have this terrific career it seems
like you get to do pretty much whatever
you you wanted and then I heard recently
that you said you were interested you
actually there's something you've wanted
to do in film that you haven't gotten a
chance to do well I actually in Tallulah
I get to do an amazing stunt and which I
won't give away but just say that it was
it I still have a pulled groin muscle
from it so if that doesn't get you to go
see the movie then I don't know what
well anyway I think that does that like
okay you got do that one stunt but you
kind of want to kind of make me like I
want to be in Kill Bill you know five or
sixth one is I like I want to be an
action hero and do you know kick ass and
and do you know I I just I'm ready for
it in fact I wanted to I wanted to do
something on your show and show you how
I how skilled I am and I suggested that
we do some sort of you know
choreographed stunt thing and and your
but your producer said that you would
not be into that so we let it drop he
said he he just said that on his own cuz
I didn't even hear about this you didn't
know it's not like it would've been a
cool
Nick set he said you were not into that
sort of any kind of physical activity no
yes that's true
but no I'm sure it being serious like if
you would wanted to do that we would
have done that in a heart here you know
he's not supposed to just unilaterally
say no we don't do this was to ask me
Matt that's right get out here
let's just just take care of it okay
right out there guy yeah why didn't you
tell me about this I didn't think it was
a good idea well let me just you didn't
think it was a good idea
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just what I was looking for trash out
here
[Applause]
any day that was sexy that was very sexy
you